bonsoir à vous dave perkins à merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur ft france
d'accord on revient évidemment sur le
vote
de nombreux républicains en faveur de ce
budget pour la défense auquel donald
trump avait opposé son veto que se
passe-t-il donald trump il est lâché par
par les siens ça y est les rats quittent
le navire maintenant je pense que le
congrès n'a jamais été un grand soutien
de donald trump l'appareil législatif là
à garder à distance a toujours souhaité
son bep son départ du côté républicain
ou démocrate au sein de la chambre et du
sénat parce que se présente un jamais
fait ce qu'ils voulaient lui faire faire
la plupart des membres du congrès
considère que donald trump est en fin de
mandat sera parti d'ici à un mois
et ils veulent donc rétablir le système
qui leur était bénéfique que donald
trump a essayé de supprimer que d'un
trump a promis et de supprimer lors de
sa campagne électorale en 2007 c'était
une de ses grandes promesses électorales
il a dit qu'il allait ramener les
soldats de cellule n'avait pas besoin
d'être où il ne faisait pas de
différence et de réutiliser toutes ces
dépenses de les réorienter vers d'autres
objectifs plus utile et donald trump a
rapatrié beaucoup d'autres soldats de
beaucoup de missions qui n'étaient pas
justifiable et je pense que le complexe
industriel au militaire s'apprête à
relancer la dépense permanente d'argent
le déploiement de troupes à l'étranger
ce qui s'est dépensé autant d'argent qui
finit dans les poches de politiciens et
d'industriels c'est une ressource qui
leur a bien manqué au cours des quatre
dernières années et qu'ils sont heureux
de pouvoir relancer ce flux de mener
maintenant corps maintenant que donald
trump va bientôt partir ça veut dire que
la fin du mental de donald trump
s'annonce vraiment difficile en bois cd
pouvoir à joe biden au mois de janvier
je ne pense pas que cela sera difficile
je pense que donald trump fait de son
mieux pour utiliser le pouvoir dont il
dispose encore pour honorer les
promesses qu'il reste à honorer son
expression est souvent chaotique on a du
mal à le suivre mais je pense que c'est
une façon pour lui de mettre ses
opposants sur la défensive et il réussit
à obtenir ses objectifs beaucoup plus de
personnes pensent qu'il est déjà parti
il est plus difficile maintenant tu pour
lui de réussir mais je pense
effectivement en l'occurrence que ce
veto va être contournée et cela
permettra aux peuples de deux foires de
repérer les personnes qui leur poseront
problème à l'avenir au sein de
l'administration
donald trump fait de son mieux et ces
gens essayent maintenant de le pousser
au bord du gouffre 1 c'est l'argent qui
parle et on est en train de revenir à
l'ancienne façon de faire les choses
donc il y aura une lutte autour de cela
à long terme
ça veut dire que le sénat va aller dans
le même sens
senna je pense va vouloir contourner ce
veto car je ne pense pas que donald
trump de beaucoup de soutien au sein du
sénat
il faudrait une majorité de deux tiers
et comme la presse que la quasi majorité
du sert et à constituer des démocrates
alors ils seront le besoin d'un très
léger nombre de républicains et il y
avait réitéré qu'ils ont affirmé à
plusieurs reprises leurs mails par
donald trump et ils n'hésiteront pas à
voter contre ce veto j'ai du mal à
suivre ce qui se passe c'est donc
j'essaie de suivre mais je pense
effectivement que donald trump se verra
contrer dans les deux chambres
alors on disait donald trump lâcher ou
pas par son camp le vice président
américain lui a refusé de donner son
aval à l'initiative de certains
républicains qui cherchent à faire
annuler la certification de la victoire
de joe biden par le congrès le 6 janvier
prochain
est ce que c'est le signe d'une rupture
entre mike pence et donald trump
je pense que mike pence et de notre
offre reste cohérent restent proches et
je ne pense pas que le vice-président
l'abandonner ne serait ce que d'un pour
cent
les soutiens de donald trump le reste à
ses côtés quelle que soit l'opinion
générale est et je dois me rend fier
contre un de ses soutiens je peux vous
garantir que quelles que soient les
actions de donald trump à l'avenir mike
pence n'est pas si important dans ce
contexte c'est vraiment donald trump qui
est au centre de cet élan et je ne pense
pas que les soutiens de donald trump
vont se décourager vont perdre leur
enthousiasme pour donald trump et pour
son programme cela va continuer c'est le
plus grand mouvement de l'histoire de la
politique américaine depuis un siècle
c'est très grand et cela va rester
important alors vous êtes un soutien de
le trump donc vous vous continuez à le
soutenir mais vu de l'extérieur c'est
vrai que cette défiance présumé de mike
pence à son égard ça pourrait aussi
révéler une perte de crédibilité de
donald trump dans le champ politique
américain cela peut révéler des
difficultés mais pour ma peine c'est pas
pour donald trump l'opinion des gens
envers tel ce n'est pas très importante
macbeth lui-même n'est pas si important
que cela il n'a pas vraiment beaucoup
d'importance en tant que candidat futur
et e
donald trump a choisi un ris président
il a choisi un bon vice président
si le vice président on doit mettre de
la distance entre lui même et notre
homme cela va être
au grand dam de mike pence et pas de
donald trump ou de ses soutiens selon
vous l'avenir du tropisme a encore de
beaux jours devant lui pour le mouvement
ou pour l'homme l'homme c'est certain va
rester une super star des médias une
personnalité à l'horizon pour les
démocrates qui au cours des quatre
prochaines années et pourrait être à
nouveau candidat en 2024
il aura le pouvoir nécessaire le soutien
nécessaire le tropisme c'est que trump
ne dit pas des choses que les gens ne
croient pas ils n'essayent pas de vous
induire en erreur
il dit des choses très simples que
depuis longtemps les américains espèrent
que des hommes politiques auront le
courage de dire de la trempe le dit on
attend plf et les américains
n'oublieront pas de mouvement restera
fort restera puissant car le peuple
attendra toujours certaines choses de
son gouvernement et si le gouvernement
rejet ça ne tient pas ses promesses
alors il y aura des dégâts de politique
je pense que donald trump restera très
puissante pour beaucoup d'années merci à
vous d'avoir king and i matin radio
analystes politiques partisans donc on
l'a bien compris de donald trump